dans notre grande serre il est parfois
bon de se laisser aller
les participants à l'atelier d'art
lyrique de l'opéra de lyon décidé
d'oublier mozart ou encore verdi le
temps du festival d'aix-en-provence et
cela pour chanter prévert et kosma
sous la direction du patron du festival
louise herlaut au coeur des répétitions
georges bigot et daniel lefebvre le
regard charles dallaire dire vous parlez
de moi mais moi j'ai mon idée et je n'en
sortirait pas sur un prétexte aussi
surréalistes et humoristique celui d'un
poème de prévert louis arnaud a imaginé
une rencontre dans le désert entre des
inconnus dont la chanson devient le
moyen de communication et de
divertissement à la maison avec ma mère
des jeunes gens qu'ils sont formés pour
le lyrique
comment ont-ils pris la chansonnette
parce qu'on leur a dit surtout votre
voix nous nous en fichons garder votre
temps votre corps mais pensez à
l'interprétation penser à intérioriser
toutes ses chansons avoir de
l'imagination de l'esprit avant de
prononcer les mots au début ça les a un
peu inquiété puis très vite très vite
ils ont tout à fait acceptée même mais
sont trouvés je dois est passionné par
cette expérience
kerber face aux pierres soupière
brouillon si possible qu'ils ont que
l'on sent derrière l'humour qui va
jaillir de cette situation
je vois